oh god I don't have a close foot oh my
god
what's up guys welcome back to the couch
I relinquished command of choosing the
game this week and Lucy's chosen it so
what you're putting me in two more three
today I'm not putting two more through
anything
he knew my I am well versed in the ways
on how to do music yeah I was gonna say
like terms face lit up when I said what
about Hatsune Miku I mean I haven't
played the games in many many many years
I'd never heard of it so what actually
is this so is the same looking thing
little bit about of a pattern in Miku
basically we know we need to know is
she's a fake virtual popstar in Japan
and she's probably more successful than
most pop stars that exist in the world
it's a rhythm our game is yeah yeah okay
so what we're gonna do Lucy will you
show off what we're doing for you we
back out and start that's her huh scene
that's gonna meet you
so the person who gets the lowest score
out of the three of us is going to have
to change their Twitter picture too and
their anime character filter you buddy
seen on Twitter each and every one ever
hang it I am NOT cool with this because
Oh mine is awful my mind is actually
kind of pretty good yeah yours is like
icon I can't rock it because I've got a
beard and so like it renders the
lipstick over my beard
no more talking to ya but like my one's
quite thick the picture that I you is it
was thick thick bie I've got a real big
game so is Lucy alright well if you're
watching you can see you can see what it
is it's press the buttons but Lucy flows
like a super easy song so get your next
menu
yeah because I've seen you practices
like eight times
yeah because right I got the Platinum on
persona hey I got a platinum on persona
4 dancing all night and I like got
really good at that game that game is
hard as well what we're gonna do to keep
it like keep it a bit mad you're gonna
do normal difficulty if you have to pick
a random song so go to the random
section wait hang on - were all doing
random yes more can I point out like go
- all look at everything that is
happening on this just go to all oh oh
oh Nick Drake's this one Alison no
choice
oh right go to the all tab just ass up
look how all the presentation was and
then just a pleasure marketing just look
at you and I'm a big fan of here
a big fan of the any male he would be
well [ __ ] I like Jonah do have no fail
mode so we can actually have a score at
the end of your breeding here and just
yet no modifiers trying to throw the
match so songs in these games are catchy
Hatsune Miku songs are catchy - hundreds
of songs she's she's got a huge backlog
for you to delve deep into this basil
actual character planners know it's
Vocaloid really yeah maybe how did we've
had a concerts happen and they did you
remember when a day 30 and member they
project a 2-pack on - she's the original
she's - Chinese Oh G Oh have you played
this on before Lucy no it's pretty
intense okay I'm gonna check elbows
[ __ ] fat so the push buzzer let's make
it easy to match at the same time jessie
3 + 5 3 + 5
the calculation pretty good I wouldn't
be able to do that I can't do that in a
normal day do plazo we are we just
watching an anime a good episode that's
pardon from the background is just
episode look it's good because if you
don't understand the we abuse oh god
your boy your boys are well into it as
you can ask me Brenda me every step of
your boys ability of boys are you boys
are all boys really into it and every
time you go to his ass he's like Denzel
and because happen in Econ at least you
can watch some cool animations that's
why I appreciate about has enemies in
video games
you're not on plans a bit arch ago it's
really creepy robotic I mean you're not
stopping anyone from pouring their heart
and soul into loving her probably know
it's pro-business I thought II don't I
don't feel comfortable giving her name
with a safe search of alabama's it's
like my every every weekend every week
enough of us just checking up over here
not so special treat yourself taking a
few look that that's a me see those
shoes the tattoo is against her skin
it's only 39 nitpick Hatsune Miku she's
more successful than you ever be they
she looks just so that all of us put
together a bear alone and I'm on Team
has an MEP
days I'm trying to figure out what the
anime the backgrounds about so far it's
just to kill the book
nice thank you how's your clothes pretty
satisfying
yeah okay protective I haven't got every
lady I know fellows got the right
remember when you google hats and Emma
coos make sure you're protected some of
those websites Nord who have known quick
AVG a business doc way booklet a new key
smoker their disappointment like s'mores
every every joke has like yeah am i
lying
only a hundred percent Jesus she's the
front of the cinema everyone trying to
watch this anime sister get the hell out
on it run
I stole confusing they're coming from
that way but Italy's Oh double is I've
I've only played the tutorial of this I
played Corona if you play games that is
before in the past I have not prepared
to give me some in many many still I
think the last year my papers okay
osanic order on this house only make it
in that there's things I've been no it's
a similar to what I've got two stage
play I mean I'm no model over those I
mean you can you hit your score top oh
that's such a Minecraft level nice right
you need to remember your score what's
the score - 6 0 0 16 oz over Nova
psychic oh my god I'm happy I made this
in Minecraft off the credit scene in
Marvel movies this is giving it was a
fury up a recruit actually done hey go
saving time you get why we're going back
alright um I don't know I said we go for
score okay two seven three two seven
three oh five three engagement you
remember that scene one got phoned come
here we've all got a phone lines are
there one two seven three oh three it's
your own duty to remove you are we're
doing a different song on the same song
yeah yeah and I have two random again
truly we shine the same song absolutely
no I'm not listen to the same song few
times I could pick I could actually pick
a harder one though that's that you can
pick it easier as well turn just hit the
road you've got we're underwater the
question why
I just want to show you all the cool off
then your last British free yeah it's
crazy
looks like she's going to a grassy space
she looks like she's in and she's
decapitate haven't arrested war him I'm
into this
I'm into that look at that which one of
you I'm hotter you obviously hit the
round the but already look at man dude
is it your own zone mister have to
appreciate there are that's something I
mean famine so cute all right angle they
fell note on you okay I haven't played
these boys diva makes head the tutorial
so amazing my lovely paid you might have
to tell me to do expired uppity and the
arranger lovely things already screwed
yourself to 73000 I mean this q70 yeah
two second three you're in the lead why
you
girl it's snowing put sleeves on voice
diva mix this is difficult this is an
opening credit requires a lot of
concentration yeah I know that's why I
wasn't talking last night
do you could use to play a lot of like
Guitar Hero
yeah I don't find any of those skills
translate well I used to play actual
guitar so if anything it made that worse
but now this is no guitars just a game
pad erupts inhales it feels pretty
different that that's the one where you
had a big hate it when games my teacher
things that famous can engage dance with
it studio no fav this one it was like a
year of Asian and it shows how you
played me did you trick me
yep I think you have wouldn't just let
go Oh dance would be make me sway what
was that song by corn covered it and it
was the word of Borrelia to the original
widows why come here yes I was actually
gonna do this just uh
like same cause screaming why touching
to me come in the post-apocalyptic world
and for our Vegas Molly talent in me I
just want to know what she's up to
trying to take an interest into her life
events oh look they trick you by making
the games big we forget to like pass
over the role wrong so yesterday I was
like making sure the games and stuff all
the sudden downloaded and I was sat
about this far away from TV that hurt
and I was wearing my glasses in it still
my eyes are gone I didn't mean to ignore
you then I was just taken away by the
fact that you handed her clone a flower
slap this happening it was figs marathon
try challenge time your life safety you
have to rack up points fold oh ha ha ha
ha chief Oh huzzah
she missed it I saw actually what
happens right I don't know in the
tutorial it says if you get the
challenge stuff you get a visual burgers
oh okay I don't know what he's hold on
hold that was so do you saw that see
what's working on there yeah what was
that about
scared Vieira see me play you want
actually clear it well yeah he's going
through life stage pairs but ok like
gana points - yeah thing we've got
turned on to the top means that you
don't run out of your life balls
so I'm sorry
take the lid they didn't die I have
considerably less place really do you
alright
oh my gosh Ryan not really I'd really
gonna change my this is a deal man
special games journalist eggs is what
happens we get a bluetick as well oh
they'll take it off you
that's an ego that's one if you change I
swear I'm not lose my blue tick okay
honey here's a Costigan did you imagine
me dreaming leaf Oh sounds awful this
one's gonna wreck your an all right
close it boys the project I'm gonna be
singing at the same time
better games them
[Music]
Hey
in all games remember to blink that was
a problem my head I've already forgotten
[Music]
its light time when you went to Japan to
go sorry okay no because I did all of
the blacking tracks have been kind of
weird like videos it got like accident
yeah I was in the arcades and I was
watching people play basically music
rhythm games and they please do not mess
about with them did you see the one
where it's like the drop oh yeah I
played that it hurts your wrist guys
they are clearly like spending most of
their lifetimes dedicated to these kind
of effect them did you have so many
Bad's I did you they are deafening I
want to play bass
[Music]
ah I don't feel like we should say I
caught that one so the powers of lyrics
first of all right I don't know what you
mean
Dawson's Jack I didn't know that yet
[Music]
I think this is flashing red and yellow
means of Ori failed like I'm so behind
the eight-ball I can't get back feeling
to you give me any poker he wins
what's Japanese for most naka de binary
mutton thanks for ha we share my
precious loves sorry what dreaming
dreaming leave for you challenge someone
say here this challenge time
trackingpoint wrong Rob this game is
like you can watch a bit of like weird
clips from animes anime movies this is
some catchy music you coded me Harry
okey it's like multi-purpose video game
[Music]
don't be over yet but she always has the
exact same expression come on dad
dead inside when lightning was like a
brand ambassador I think a lot oh yeah
and someone interviewed like this this
[ __ ] my song was as long as yours
yeah yeah Dave Junko yo yes all right
get me some point this is the first can
we do the song that you had during the
training mode just nice and oh video
this game you see guys fight Reinhard
try the hardest song yeah hold on hold
the guys with the capo tonight I'm lucid
dreaming oh I thought that was like the
friends first
yeah this is the Tudor family no FOMO
turn on this is so I've got to change my
patient is horrible yet you guys so when
we did the the tutorial it's this song
and it is so this is just in all the
videos online
I don't realize it was a bit big in me
classic it's big in the dopamine
committee thing oh my god snap stops
family a minute
no signal
[Music]
this is the only one I like my the
others so safe and I think that's the
first challenge based let's play that
I've lost I can I go and think of a
flying again rather lyrics you don't
understand what's happening
yes I knew the law you said it was
gibberish gibberish Japanese language
all this song in particular I mean I'm
fairly certain this is in Japanese words
and my Japanese isn't amazing she's got
the leak back aleka's back I'm suddenly
as I'm a fairly common song like I've
heard other doctor makes man at minimum
it man man he's thinking she says likes
Istanbul Sicily I've definitely had
other people thinking this economy is
probably one of those life is free music
yeah oh god I don't wanna close below oh
my god Lucille the video is so creepy
it's like a mean video
she's too happy I downloaded a new
outfit as well and I didn't even get to
wear it crackers applying online sound
drag December 2017 or so when polka was
hot excuse me
it's just her dead eyes and fixed
expressions are you comfortable I thank
you not to talk [ __ ] about autonomy
please we think she's gonna come up and
defend you you ever get in trouble
she don't care about you man she doesn't
even know you exist she's not mine and
my wife yeah she's home your waifu man
on man sues your wife fear got respected
this is a lot higher than the screen
round there's a lot going on there's a
lot of colors
well that was experience why I guess I'm
gonna go change my Twitter profile
picture what up change outfit hey many
me I want to vote it's also again I
wanna see what y'all she's let's look at
some of our whatever my job we got
rhythm rhythm game custom plans do
customization please thank you
tears modules oh what's this
I bought I bought one of them there's a
whole squad did you not know this what's
wrong with you guys
nothing purple
I think that's just a different
character yeah hello you guys get weird
about these outfits I'm gonna say thank
you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed I know
wait hair pose make sure you hit that
like button
I mean I'm trying to end it I'm
absolutely on ear fly the video goodbye
forever
I'm Way too casual fascia
[Music]